bonjour comment allez vous il est 6
heures du matin il est beaucoup trop tôt
et c'est la vingtième ouverture de ce
calendrier de l'avent aujourd'hui je
vous parlais d'un bouquin pas n'importe
lequel
l'année dernière 2016 sur le mental blog
vous avez parlé de alex au pays des
chiffres qui fait partie de la
collection champs sciences de chez
flammarion on dit ça c'est pas si facile
a dit faire trinquer
c'était entre la entre le livre
scientifique et le conte merveilleux
c'était vraiment génial et du coup j'ai
continué à être fidèle à cette
collection là et à en prendre
il ya deux bouquins qui je pense ont des
bonnes idées de cadeaux si c'est le
genre de dealer que vous aimez y en a un
qui est fabuleux s'appelle la réalité
cachée c'est celui ci en fait à l'issue
de ce bouquin on déstabilise un truc
scientifique un petit peu comme le jour
où on s'est dit maintenant en fait le
soleil n'est pas le centre de l'univers
est bien là tout ce bouquin est basé sur
la théorie du multivers et sur le fait
que plus en avance puis cette hypothèse
est plus qu'intéressante et viable donc
on repart de toutes les bases du boson
de higgs découvert en 2012 des théories
d'einstein des découvertes récentes et
au final c'est vraiment un regard
hypothétique par contre détaillé source
et est accessible sur le multivers elle
donc dans ces cas là le fait qu' on fait
partie d'un tout beaucoup plus grand et
que l'univers n'est pas ce tout n'est
qu'une infime partie de ce tout et donc
après il ya les hypothèses et les
théories dans la théorie par exemple
est-ce qu en fait tous ces univers lane
ne serait pas superposer et c'est à dire
à des vibrations ou à des éléments
différents mais que à quelques
millimètres de nous il y a déjà ses
superpositions d'univers est-ce que
c'est d'aider espèce de bras nous
demandera comme ils disent dans la
théorie des cordes
bref ça se lit comme un scénario de sf
sauf que c'est pas de la sf et ça c'est
génial et aussi dans la même collection
j'ai bien aimé ça c'était plus dans le
début d'année une belle histoire de loeb
ou là on parle de plein de choses
intéressantes mais d'un point de vue là
on se recentre sur la planète terre par
exemple le chaînon manquant qui est le
vraiment le premier homme à être apparu
on va parler aussi
à l'intérieur de comment ça c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on essaie de guerre sur
terre comment on en est arrivé là sur la
surpopulation qui est pas un phénomène
anecdotique qui c'est à dire que tous
les animaux auto réguler leur population
en fonction des ressources qu'ils ont et
nous sommes les seuls à pas le faire et
pour l'instant les seuls organismes
vivants qu'ils ne te régule pas leurs
populations sont les virus les bactéries
et tous les parasites
voilà hyper intéressant aussi avec des
solos des questions comme d'où vient le
fait qu'on sur les seuls à parler
est ce qu'on est vraiment les seuls à
parler est-ce qu'on arriverait encore à
se nourrir en 2050
bref ça se lit très bien aussi c'est
beaucoup d'interrogations n'ya pas
toujours toutes les réponses dans ses
interrogations
mais il ya des pistes de réflexion très
intéressante je vous mets ça ça et puis
je vous remettrez lui tient qui était
génial dans la description dans la
description je veux mais également
quelque chose de très divertissant est
très intéressant mais très faible en
même temps c'est une soirée qu'elle ait
lieu le 22 septembre 2018 à l'olympia
une place pour ça c'est une bonne idée
de cadeau et c'est mon spectacle
n'hésitez pas à liker la vidéo à vous
abonner à me donner votre avis sur ces
livres là si vous les avez lu dans les
commentaires et rendez vous demain à 6
heures du matin cha haut
[Musique]
au
oh
non
[Musique]
vous
bon